[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout le monde
vous voyez ce que je vais faire je viens
de vous saluer ici je pense que tout le
monde a compris que je voulais dire
bonjour dans certaines régions du monde
on dit bonjour la même façon en france
on se donne à bize au tibet on va tirer
la langue et dans certaines tribus
d'afrique de l'est
on va cracher au pied notre
interlocuteur et non qu'on n'a pas tous
les mêmes codes culturels comme on peut
voir mais y'en a qui se ressemblent si
je refais le premier signe je vous dis
rail ni à aulas vous comprenez pas
nécessairement ce que je dis mais parce
que vous vous reconnaissez le signe vous
savez ce que je veux dire
par contre si quelqu'un arrive et
commence à vous donner des bisous sur
les joues bien vous savez pas qui veut
dire bonjour
vous allez penser que cette personne ait
un peu trop affectueuse
si quelqu'un du maire vous faire des
grimaces
vous allez risque il faut risquer de
penser que c'est un comique ici
quelqu'un vous crache au pied vous
risquez d'être insultée donc on n'a pas
tous les mêmes codes culturels
mais y en a qui se ressemble et qui
reviennent dans chacune des cultures
proporta la culture on a une façon de se
dire bonjour on aussi la curiosité
cette soif d'apprendre peu importe qui
on est et d'où on vient et on à la
nourriture on a tous besoin de manger
on aime tous mangé et la nourriture est
préparé différemment d'un endroit à
l'autre
avant d'aller plus loin je pense que
c'est important qu'on prenne une petite
seconde et consentants tueur c'est quoi
une culture personnellement j'aime bien
la définition du curé français armand
farrachi pour lui une culture c'est
l'ensemble des connaissances les
savoir-faire les traditions des coutumes
propres un groupe humain une
civilisation
elle se transmet socialement de
génération en génération et non par
l'héritage génétique et conditionne en
grande partie les comportements
individuels et donc comme on peut le
voir une culture
c'est pas on y va on voit pas de maître
avec ça on est le produit de notre
environnement
quand je parle à mes grands parents puis
commence à me raconter des histoires sur
leur jeunesse
je trouve ça fascinant mais ça se passe
dans un monde que je reconnais plus ou
moins sûr monde où il y avait deux
façons d'avoir du lait attendre le
laitier ou avoir une vache seulement
nous les professeurs c'était des
religieux où des religieuses mais
surtout sur un monde où l'on mangeait
pas de pizza
j'ai rien contre la nourriture
traditionnelle québécoise n'est pas de
calais mes amis vont vous dire que
j'adore la tourtière
mais le monde tellement plus de saveur
nous offrir que ça mais il ya 50 ans un
événement qui va changer complètement la
façon dont les québécois vont vivre leur
vie et qui va révolutionner nos
habitudes alimentaires
cet événement là si l'expo 67
l'expo 67 c'est le moment où le québec
va s'ouvrir au monde
c'est le moment où on découvrit plat
comme des tacots des sushis puis bien
évidemment des pizzas pour beaucoup des
gens qui vont aller à l'expo 67
ça va être une des premières fois où
vous êtes exposés à une culture qui est
différente que la leur il se peut rien
et ils vont tellement aimé certains des
chefs des affaires auxquelles y ont été
exposés qui vont commencer à les
apporter dans leur vie quotidienne et
les adoptés dans la vie quotidienne et
une de ces affaires-là qui est très
visible aujourd'hui
si les habitudes alimentaires à m'élever
combien d'entre vous avez une pizzeria
de quartier une pizzeria pas trop loin
de chez vous je pense que tout le monde
ici a levé la main sur sa prouve à quel
point les habitudes alimentaires au
québec ont changé du tout au tout au
contact de notre culture jours annonce
me cuisiner des plats qu'on dit chiche
daouk des eagles du spaghetti
du nombre une explosion du nombre de
restaurants libanais italiens et chinois
à montréal puis ensuite dans le reste de
la province
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on a une
diversification aussi intense de nos
habitudes alimentaires
c'est simple c'est parce qu'on a aimé ce
qu'on a vu on a aimé ce qu'on a goûté et
on a aimé ce qu'on a ressenti
on a tellement aimé ça que petit à petit
sans vraiment nous en rendre compte
on a commencé à intégrer si vous avez
alors dans notre quotidien je sais pas
si vous êtes comme moi mais est-ce que
vous commencez à avoir faim donc j'ai un
an et demi je vais arriver à québec pour
étudier à l'université laval et j'ai
choisi de venir vivre en résidence
pourquoi parce que je voulais vivre aux
nations unies je revenais d'un voyage en
sac à dos à travers l'europe
si j'avais eu la piqûre découvrir de
nouvelles cultures
mais j'avais un problème
j'avais pas une scène et c'est là
qu'entre en jeu les résidences parce que
les résidences c'est un endroit
exceptionnel qu'on retrouve nulle part
ailleurs à québec parce qu'on à 65 % des
étudiants qui vient de l'international
et on a 75 différentes nationalités qui
se côtoient au quotidien
c'est incroyable mais je dois dire que
quand je suis arrivé là c'est un choc
autant j'étais impatient d'aller à la
rencontre de toutes les cultures qui
m'entouraient autant j'avais aucune idée
comment les aborder
j'avais vraiment peur de mettre les
pieds dans les plats
mais heureusement il y avait les
cuisines je sais en revient la bouffe
dans les cuisines des résidences un peu
la cafétéria des nations unies et aux
personnes qui mangent à la même heure
chaque région du monde
au sauna donc on va regarder son temps
on commence à 17h par les québécois une
heure après il ya des latino américains
qui arrivent et quand les québécois
qu'il ya une gangue désertique qui
rentre et in situ et jusqu'à temps que
tout le monde a fini de manger belle se
coucher et font comme on peut le voir si
tu veux découvrir une nouvelle culture
macho change dont art dessous peu plus
compliqué que ça
et donc une des premières personnes que
j'ai rencontrées en résidence dans les
cuisines des résidences en fait c'est
quelqu'un qui venait comme en négatif
bravo les nations unies et cette
personne là venait de passer la dernière
année de sa vie en voyage en saccades ou
à travers l'asie
il s'est tourné la cuisiner un plat de
la mongolie
fin juin c'est la goutte et on a
commencé à jaser cuisine ni blâme
expliqué que en fait le plan quelques
usines c'était à base d'ingrédients
qu'on connaît tous et qu'on a tous dans
nos cuisines
c'est des patates des oignons gingembre
de l'ail le sel du poivre
on a tout ça on connaît tout ça mais
cette personne là les préparer de façon
totalement différente de ce à quoi on
pouvait s'attendre et donc ça tenait un
goût qui était complètement différent
parce qu'une fois qu'on a fini de
cuisiner cette personne m'a proposé de
goûter à son plat et vite évidemment
j'ai accepté et la seconde que j'ai pris
ma première bouchée je me suis
transporté le souhaitent transporter de
l'autre côté la planète juste comme ça
j'étais en mongolie et c'est à ce moment
là que j'ai réalisé à quel point la
nourriture pour être un tremplin super
utile et performant pour apprendre à
connaître l'autre et c'est comme ça que
je me suis créé un groupe d'amis une
bulle multi culturelles puis
internationales depuis je suis arrivé à
québec
une fois de temps en temps il m'arrive
de sortir de cette bulle et la réalité
le contraste entre la réalité et la
réalité de l'extérieur bien honnêtement
ça me frustre ça me frustre tellement
que j'écris le projet l'un l'autre
ce contraste là je n'en suis pas
vraiment rendu compte jusqu'à temps que
la situation explose
deux semaines après avoir commencé mon
cours sur le terrorisme à l'université
laval
j'ai un événement qui va venir
bouleverser
notre communauté ici si les attentes à
la grande mosquée de québec en janvier
et dans ce cours là notre projet de fin
d'année c'était de créer une campagne de
prévention de la radicalisation qui
ensuite allaient être mises en place par
une équipe de volontaires et qui à
l'entrée dans une compétition
interuniversitaire international il
comme cet événement m'a vraiment touché
n'était pas question que je rentre
l'opportunité de m'impliquer là bas ce
qui fait que j'ai donné mon nom et avec
mes collègues la première chose qu'on a
fait c'est qu'on a fait une petite
recherche pour voir ce qu'elle serait la
meilleure façon de s'impliquer il ya une
chose qui nous a vraiment frappé c'est
que j'ai plusieurs communautés à québec
qui se parlent pas ou presque pas et
donc pour stimuler un dialogue on a
commencé on ne crie en fait une campagne
où l'un pourrait être apprendre à
connaître l'autre d'où notre nom très
original
l'un l'autre et comment s'y prend on
fait il qu'on va interviewer des gens de
québec donc nos concitoyens et on va
choisir des extraits qu'on va publier
sur une page facebook
le but c'est de stimuler un dialogue
c'est d'apprendre à connaître l'autre
mais en même temps de découvrir le monde
et aujourd'hui vous êtes chanceux parce
que j'ai deux personnes à vous présenter
ce que certains dé rencontrer
yes alors la première personne que je
vais vous présenter aujourd'hui c'est
elle evelyne et évelyne pendant son
entrevue à venir nous parler d'identité
il du fait qu'on a tendance très souvent
inconsciemment à limiter une personne à
une seule facette de sa personnalité
alors pendant son entrevue et viennent
nous a dit ceci je suis une européenne à
québec
mon identité elle est à cheval entre
l'europe et l'afrique
en attendant sa place et l'autre dans un
moule prix fort mais elle lui demander
de gary seulement une valise or j'en ai
une française une africaine est une
québécoise
pourquoi est ce que je pourrai pas tout
les garder puisqu'elles font toutes
partie de ma personne et en parlant de
vivre ensemble et d'inclusion on à chi
l'ha parce que je suis là pendant son
entrevue voulait nous parler de
l'endroit extraordinaire où elle a la
chance d'habiter
elle me disait ceci via une belle
mosaïque de cultures et d'origines dans
mon bâtiment
elle se reflète sur le terrain quand les
enfants jouent
c'est comme si le monde se rencontrer il
ya des maghrébins des latinos et des
québécois qui s'amusent ensemble entre
autres les boîtes chicane personnes se
dit toi t'es pas comme moi
en fait on dirait qu'ils sont plus
fasciné les uns par les autres
même quand ils se comprennent pas donc
on devrait pour les enfants c'est facile
c'est normal d'aller à la rencontre de
l'autre voudrait plus haut grandit plus
ça devient compliqué
le système car quand je suis arrivé à
québec j'avais vraiment peur de mettre
les pieds dans les plats en approche un
autre mais je me suis rapidement rendu
compte que je m'en faisais beaucoup trop
pour rien
dans la plupart des cas tout ce qu'il
faut faire c'est d'approché l'autre avec
un gros sourire idiot un beau bonjour
en janvier dernier la réalité me
rattraper et aujourd'hui encore on a une
situation qui montre que la situation
cette situation aussi est loin des prix
parce qu'en même temps que je vous parle
vivre ensemble l'inclusion appui de
multiculturalisme
on a seulement quelques pas d'ici deux
groupes d'extrême droite qui manifestent
devant le parlement contre le niqab et
la commission contre la racisme
systémique et pour moi qui baigne dans
une bulle multiculturel et international
une manifestation qui fait la promotion
des valeurs de l'exclusion
j'ai peint de la misère avec ça
personnellement je peux pas supporter ça
et donc pour faire contrepoids à la
radicalisation et l extrémisme
je vous invite à aller à la rencontre de
l'autre
vous l'avez probablement deviné ma façon
préférée de le faire c'est avec la
nourriture
mais il existe mille et une façons de le
faire
ça peut être par le spar par les arts et
bien évidemment par la page facebook de
l'un l'autre
pendant ces rencontres là vous allez non
seulement découvrir un individu
extraordinaire devant vous mais vous
allez vous allez aussi découvrir une
nouvelle culture une nouvelle partie du
monde mais en plus de ça vous allez
découvrir une nouvelle partie de vous
même que vous soupçonnez même pas parce
que vraiment dans le fond découvrir
l'autre c'est aussi se découvrir
soi-même
merci
[Applaudissements]